en we hopen dat er op
basis van de rest staat van het onderzoek
1 mooie locatie gevonden kan worden
om eeuwig plek te geven
aan de gastarbeiders
in Amsterdam
locatie die ontworpen wordt om meer dan 1 monument
te zijn 1 plek waar verhalen van moed
diversiteit en veerkracht samen komen
1 plek waar toekomstige generaties kunnen leren
over de waarde
en waarderen wat deze dappere mannen
en vrouwen voor onze stad hebben
betekent
over de betekenis van deze geschiedenis van Amsterdam
van nu en de toekomst
en met ons
iniciatief voorstel willen we het verleden Eren
en de nieuwsgierigheid weer opnieuw aanwakkeren
dat nakomelingen van gastarbeiders
maar ook juist amsterdamers
die voor wie deze geschiedenis misschien nieuw is
hierover kunnen leren
dit voorstel gaat over het gezicht geven aan de velen
prachtige moedige verhalen
van de eerste generatie gastarbeiders
die vanuit
verschillende plekken gevraagd zijn hiernaartoe
te komen en dat ook de toekomstige generaties
kunnen leren van die levenslessen
en zal helpen om hun eigen identiteit te omarmen
het is van crucial belang
dat dit moment autentie aansluit bij de verhalen
de strijd de prestaties van de gasarbijders
die 1 fundamentale rol hebben gespeeld in de opbouw
van onze stad
nogmaals complimenten
we omarmen dat volledige als eh college
we gaan niet meer aan de slag
en dan eh komen er alleen maar mooie dingen uit